we often hear from people that you can't
make money
making films short films feature films
is there a way to make money from it or
is that not
that shouldn't be your goal starting out
well so
i do think that you can make money from
the film industry i mean clearly people
make millions of dollars
these there are some beautiful houses in
la that was built
on film money i do think that you can
make money from a film
i think what a lot of times filmmakers
initially do
even with the short films they forget to
pay themselves and so
what i've started to do even in a line
item of a film that i've invested my own
money in
i still will put one dollar for myself
and it's to continue to train myself to
realize that i do have a monetary value
that is attached to who i am and what i
do
but what i think also oftentimes that
filmmakers do
is and this is what they should do
whenever you're putting a budget
together for a feature film you have to
also think about the life of what that
film
is going to be right so if you're going
to live with that film for six months
you also need to make sure that your
expenses are covered for six months
so part of your budget when you're
establishing your budget should
be to have money to pay you as a
director to live for those six months
that's one of the things that techniques
that i didn't do very early on but now i
actually
absolutely i'm like was this a two-month
process i needed two months of this kind
of money from the budget
and so i state that up front and also
one thing that i would also say that i
think filmmakers should absolutely do
is say what you need as well right
because we always speak from a place of
just talking about the project
making sure the project we want to make
sure the project has
the right camera we want to make sure it
has the right light in the right
location the right actors
but the project comes from a person so
you also have to make sure
you as a person has what you need
to be okay as well and so whenever i
talk to filmmakers i preach that from
the very beginning make sure that you
pay yourself
as a part of the process but as far as
the
film's ability to be monetized and to
make money
there are people whose job is to do that
and you should go find those people and
make sure that you get in contact with
those people
to make that happen because it's not our
job
to make the money it's our job to create
the product
and make the money after it's out or get
paid
up front well i think a filmmaker should
definitely get paid up front
for their fees i think they should also
negotiate
some type of ownership in the project as
well
however whatever you get initially
whatever that initial sale is on your
film is all the money that you will get
like period point blank i have not heard
of a film doing amazing at the box
office and then a filmmaker making
millions
with certain level of ownership so you
also have to come in from a very
realistic place
as well so that's what i would advise
somebody to do
you should be a line item in the budget
you should own some of your product
but that initial sale you should benefit
from that as well
that initial distribution sale that's
where you're going to get your money
you're not going to get no more money
after that
can you give us some examples of ways
you've been able to make money
with films or stage plays sure so
primarily how i've been able to make my
money over the past three years have
been in short form digital content
and so one of the ways that you can do
it is
you figure out what networks are
actually looking for
from time frame to
what specifically has to be inside the
frame and so i end up making brooklyn
blue sky for about
seven thousand five hundred dollars i
got another small investment on the back
end to do some editing
and then i was able to send those
projects over to bet
as i knew bet was starting to look for
digital content because we were
initially going to just put it on the
internet
but we started working with this
producer named chris hicks and he was
like no
like bet is actively looking for content
so we were able to license the content
at a pretty nice rate per
episode and so that was able to pay the
budget back but then
because i had ownership in the series i
was able to use that money
to live off of for an entire year
um i also was able to do that with saws
the project with that as well except
they gave us a big budget from the very
beginning and we negotiated a larger
budget
and then we just held some of that money
back for me to actually get paid in
order to do
what i needed to do um later on down the
line
so if you make a project for a little
bit amount of money but you're able to
get a larger licensing fee
that'll be able to give you some actual
revenue
that you're able to to create along the
way so mostly it's been short form
content it's been short
our content because people are looking
to fill up those content
avenues in the content arenas also i've
been able to
work and recently start working with
different brands who are looking to
create content as well short form
digital content because that's of course
my specialty
and from that you can also make money as
well because a lot of brands are looking
for their stories to be told
in a very linear digital way and so
you're able to utilize that as well
different brands work with them in order
to create stories
and you can make money off that as well
and did those brands approach you or you
were already working with someone who
was working with those brands so i
actually approached the brand
believe it or not sometimes the empty
mouth just doesn't get fed
so i would put together a small package
i did it for a wine company i did it for
another
liquor company i said hey i make short
form content this is what my views have
been
combined with your talent and your
resources
it could be much more and this is a
story idea that i have for you
and here's how we would do it and this
is what it would look like and two of
those brands
picked up on it and that's another way
that i'm able to use my storytelling
abilities
in order to to make money and did you
research which brands you should go
after did you say i think
i would be right for this one or so with
one liquor brand i had a friend that
worked in that field so i
already had a direct connect and then
the other one was a connect through
a manager that i had and she was able to
connect me over to them and i was able
to pitch it
but i know in the next year or so that's
what i'll be working on a little bit
more
that'll be a separate side of my
production company where we actually
really start to churn those different
types of projects out
and um how do you contact those people
do you send an email like oh just a
quick pitch
you can do a quick pitch a lot of times
a deck
some type of visual deck for them to be
able to see really works
a lot of times people don't know what
they want until they actually you show
them
what they want and then it makes sense
and also you're able to create something
at a much lower price point than they
would they're able to make commercials
at
so they look at you and they're like oh
this only costs 250 000
we get eight episodes at 10 minutes
apiece as opposed to them putting 1.2
million dollars into a commercial that's
30 seconds long
and so it is an attractive bid for a
brand to be able to create content
because they have the budgets
to be able to put more content and
everybody's into storytelling right now
so they have the money to be able to put
those things out there
and so are you once you have the budget
then you're finding the talent or they
already have people in mind
so i manage the projects as as they're
my own projects with taking advisement
from them
a lot of times brand don't necessarily
have talent because it's a very new
thing
to use brands in order to tell stories
so it could be a story about a guy who
needs to find his dog
and the brand could be about dog food so
yeah they may have
like an idea or two but most of the time
for me what i've seen is they just allow
me to go out there and to procure the
talent to
create and to make the production
you